I got into a little lab backs in it and
I'm still making a video hardcore
science Asylum Nick lucid here polska
Pro was wondering there's an absolute
zero
why is there no absolute hot very good
question polska Pro let's see what we
can do we saw in the last video the
temperature was the average random
kinetic energy per molecule if you want
more detail go watch that one first if
temperature is kinetic energy the zero
temperature is zero kinetic energy
absolute zero is literally no motion
having motion less than none doesn't
even make sense so zero is the lower
limit by that same reasoning the higher
the temperature the more kinetic energy
there is even though the speed of light
is the upper speed limit kinetic energy
blows up to infinity at that speed so
that doesn't appear to be an upper limit
that being said there might be Sagar
Sharma brought up the plunk temperature
it's 2.5 5 times 10 to the 32 degrees
Fahrenheit or 1.4 2 times 10 to the 32
degrees Celsius or Kelvin for that
matter it's so hot you could just say 10
to the 32 and call it a day no unit
necessary that's a 1 followed by zero
zero zero zero zero is 32 zeroes no one
can comprehend such numbers there are
actually many plot numbers all of which
represent the limits of what we know
about physics but just because we don't
understand how to temperatures it
doesn't mean they don't exist
luckily the universe has only been that
hot once when it was very young so let
us know in the comments what's the
hottest you've ever been in any meaning
of the word wink wink and until next
time remember it's okay to be a little
crazy